Grammy nominated though like and opening
and singing with Taylor Swift you
know I mean what what does it feel like
when you get that call you've been
nominated for a gry and not an obscure
category Best New Artist what does it
feel like it's it's such a Trippy honor
and it feels like a fever dream and it
hasn't quite landed but I'm just the
biggest fan of everyone who's in the
category that I for some reason I'm like
I feel like I'm crashing the party a
little bit you know what I mean no and
I'm so grateful that answer it's so like
human humble normal that's that's a
great answer it's like yeah it is a
little of like wait what's happening yay
whoo it's strange but it's so lucky and
I
yeah